KNOW HOW JAMES O'KEEFE WORKS.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THE STORY.
BUT FIRST, JOINING US WITH
REACTION TO OTHER BREAKING NEWS
THAT WE HAVE, ROBERT MUELLER HAS
AGREED TO TESTIFY PURSUANT TO A
SUBPOENA.
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT AT LARGE
GERALDO RIVERA, FORMER
SECRET SERVICE AGENT AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
DAN BONGINO.
A, I DON'T THINK WE CAN GO BACK
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IT
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE II
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IK
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IW
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IE
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IB
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IT
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IH
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IL
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IV
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IE
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IH
TO GERALDO ON TEHRAN, BECAUSE IM
SO MUCH THAT WE MAY END UP
HAVING A BRAWL THE NEXT TIME WE
SEE EACH OTHER, WHICH IS NOT
TRUE.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, LET'S
START WITH MUELLER.
MUELLER WAS CLEAR, THE AG WAS
CLEAR, MUELLER'S REPORT ON THE
ISSUE OF COLLUSION,
CONSPIRACY -- THAT WAS THE
FOURTH TIME WE HEARD NO.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS WANT A FIFTH
BITE AT THE APPLE.
NOW THEY ARE HARASSING AND
ABUSING THEIR POWER, THEY ARE
HARASSING THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS ISN'T OVERSIGHT, THIS IS
NOW TRY AND HARASS THE PRESIDENT
TIME, AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE
AG SAID THAT DECISION IS
DETERMINED BY HIM,
ROD ROSENSTEIN, AND EVEN THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL WEIGHED
IN.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
SO I GUESS THE QUESTION HERE IS,
MUELLER HAS SAID -- I'M JUST
GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT IS IN THE
REPORT AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN, SO WHY?
>> THIS MAY BE A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY.
NUMBER ONE, WYATT -- NADLER IS
NOT REALLY THAT BRIGHT, SEAN, HE
SCREWED THIS THING UP FROM THE
START.
FROM BRINGING IN PEOPLE FROM THE
NIXON ERA WHO PROCEEDED TO
HUMILIATE THEMSELVES IN FRONT OF
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS, TO
ASKING HOPE HICKS, CALLING HER
MRS. LEWANDOWSKI.
NADLER HAS MEDIATED HIMSELF, THE
DEMOCRATS KNOW IT.
BUT HERE'S THE KEY QUESTION,
THIS IS WHY IT IS GOING TO BLOW
UP IN THEIR FACE.
ONE REPUBLICAN, I'M SURE, IS
GOING TO ASK MUELLER THE KEY
QUESTION: WHAT EXACTLY DID YOU
KNOW THE COLLUSION FAIRY TALE
WAS A HOAX?
THE ANSWER, IF MUELLER IS
HONEST, IS THE DAY I HIRED
ANDREW WEISSMANN, BECAUSE
ANDREW WEISSMANN, SEAN, WAS
BRIEFED A YEAR EARLIER, 2016, O-
>> Sean: 2016.
HIS PITBULL, NUMBER ONE GUY ONE
GUY --
>> YES!
>> Sean: VICTORY PARTY.
ALSO LICENSED TO LIE, SIDNEY
POWELL'S HUGE BOOK, EXPOSING ALL
OF HIS CORRUPTION, THEREFORE THE
WORLD TO READ, AND I URGE PEOPLE
TO READ IT.
GERALDO, AFTER THE NINE AND A
HALF MINUTE -- WELL,
ROBERT MUELLER STATEMENT, THAT
THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR ANY
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE HAD TO
CLEAN UP BADLY, AND I THINK
FRANKLY, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
THREE MUELLER A LIFELINE,
BECAUSE DIDN'T REMEMBER WHAT HE
SAID WHAT HE WRITE IT, OR HE
DOESN'T KNOW, WHICH IS EVEN
WORSE.
WHY DO I SUSPECT -- THIS IS NOT
GOING TO GO WELL FOR HIM AT ALL.
>> IT ISN'T.
WE ARE GOING BACK DOWN MEMORY
LANE.
NADLER AND SHIFT REMIND ME OF
HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES, THEY
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL, AND
NOW NOBODY RECOGNIZES THEM.
THEY ARE OFFENDED THAT THEY ARE
OUTSIDE THE MAINSTREAM OF PUBLIC
CONSCIOUSNESS NOW.
NOBODY KNOWS WHO THEY ARE OR
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY HAVE BEEN FORGOTTEN, SO
THEY ARE DESPERATE FOR
ATTENTION, DRAGGING BACK
ROBERT MUELLER.
ROBERT MUELLER HAS ALREADY TOLD
THEM, IN NO UNCERTAIN TERMS,
THAT HIS TESTIMONY WILL STICK
EXACTLY TO THE MOTHER REPORTED.
IT IS THERE, ALL IN WRITING, AND
PEOPLE ARE TRULY INTERESTED IN
IT, I'M INTERESTED IN THE
CONCLUSION TO THE CONCLUSION
SAID THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT A TRAITOR
TO THE UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT A SPY FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN WRONGLY
ACCUSED FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS, HAD HIS ADMINISTRATION
JUST SO BOTHERED, SO
HARASSED BY THESE POLITICAL
OPERATIVES --
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
APPEARED TO BE GONE YET HE HAS
MANAGED TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Sean: LET'S IMAGINE
JIM JORDAN, , AND OTHERS HAVE A
CHANCE TO QUESTION MUELLER PAIR
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHEN HE KNEW
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
YOU HAD A BROAD MANDATE, WHEN
DID YOU HAVE TIME FOR VIOLATIONS
THAT ARE NEVER INVOKED, AND TAXI
MEDALLIONS, AND LONE
APPLICATIONS, AND TAX
VIOLATIONS -- BY THE WAY, ALWAYS
PAY YOUR TAXES, DON'T LIE ON
LOAN APPLICATIONS, WE'VE GOT IT.
BUT WITH THE BROAD MANDATE, HE
DIDN'T LOOK AT ALL INTO THE
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SUSPECT WAS
ALWAYS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION?
HOW DOES HE ANSWER,
LEGITIMATELY, THAT QUESTION?
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANY GOOD ANSWER TO THAT QUESTIO
QUESTION?
>> NOR IS THERE A GOOD ANSWER --
I'M SORRY, DAN.
GO AHEAD.
>> I JUST WANTED TO BRING UP
THIS POINT.
REMEMBER, MUELLER WAS HIRED IN
MAY 2017, SEAN.
IN JULY OF 2017, HOROWITZ TURNS
OVER TO MUELLER'S TEAM THE
PETER STRZOK TEXT.
HOW DOES MUELLER CONTINUE HIS
INVESTIGATION AT THAT POINT?
NOTICE WHAT HE DOES AFTER THAT,
MUELLER DOESN'T STOP THE
INVESTIGATION -- HE DOUBLED
DOWN.
HE RAIDS PAUL MANAFORT'S HOUSE
IN THE MORNING FROM HE GOES AND
PICKS UP PAPADOPOULOS AT THE
AIRPORT, HOUSES FBI AGENTS DO
IT.
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION WAS A
HOAX FROM THE BEGINNING.
THE REPORT IS THE SAME.
>> Sean: I GOT ANOTHER
QUESTION.
GERALDO, HOW DOES HE POSSIBLY
ANSWER THE QUESTION --
ANDREW WEISSMANN, HIS PITBULL,
OKAY, HE WAS AT HILLARY'S
VICTORY PARTY.
ANDREW WEISSMANN IS PITBULL,
LICENSED TO LIVE, TALKS ABOUT
HOW HE WITHHELD EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE, HOW TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS LOST HIS JOB, LOST
9-0 IN THE SUPREME COURT, SENT
EXECUTIVES THAT WERE INNOCENT TO
JAIL, THAT WAS OVERTURNED BY THE
FIFTH CIRCUIT, AND ALSO HIRED
HILLARY'S ATTORNEY AT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION, AND THEY
WERE ALL DEMOCRATS APPEARED HE
COULDN'T FIND ONE REPUBLICAN?
HOW IS MUELLER GOING TO ANSWER
THAT ONE?
I DON'T THINK THAT IS GOING TO
BE VERY COMFORTABLE FOR
ROBERT MUELLER.
>> HOW IS HE GOING TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION: HOW DARE YOU RUIN THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE LIKE
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN?
HOW DARE YOU --
>> Sean: BINGO.
>> WHEN THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
WITH THE RUSSIANS, YOU STUCK
WITH THIS THING, YOU MADE THESE
PEOPLE WORK
THEMSELVES INTO PERJURY TRAPS,
YOU SLAMMED THEM WITH THESE
PROCEDURAL OFFENSES, YOU WRECKED
THEIR LIVES, YOU DISTRACTED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT THE PRICE THAT THIS
TESTIMONY WILL COST THE
DEMOCRATS WILL BE GRIEVOUS TO
THEM.
THEY WILL RUE THE DAY THAT
NADLER AND SCHIFF LET THEIR
AMBITION GET AHEAD OF THEIR
COMMON SENSE, THEIR POLITICAL
SCIENCE, AND DRAG THIS MAN BACK
INTO CENTER STAGE OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
>> Sean: NOW WE KNOW THAT
FLYNN TALKS TO THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR, McCABE, BECAUSE FBI
GUYS -- HE ASKED, DO I NEED A
LAWYER?
OH, NO, YOU DON'T NEED A LAWYER.
OKAY.
THEN COMEY IS BRAGGING, IN HIS
WAY, OH, I TOOK FULL ADVANTAGE
OF THE CHAOS, SOMETHING I WOULD
NEVER DO IN THE OBAMA OR BUSH
ADMINISTRATIONS.
I SENT MY GUYS IN THERE, WHAT,
TO SCREW A 33 YEAR VETERAN WHO
SERVED IN COMBAT, THIS COUNTRY?
AND THEN THERE IS MORE TO IT --
>> AND THEY DID IT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE!
>> DON'T TELL ANYBODY WHAT IS
GOING ON.
>> Sean: THEY KNEW EVERYTHING
HE SAID, AND SAID YOU DON'T NEED
A LAWYER.
AND THE FBI STILL DIDN'T THINK
HE LIED TO HIM!
BUT HE GOT BANKRUPT, THREATENED
HIS KID AND HIS FAMILY, WE WILL
TAKE YOUR SON DOWN WITH YOU, AND
HE FELL ON THE SWORD LIKE ANY
GOOD FATHER WOULD DO.
DAN BONGINO, I KNOW YOU WOULD DO
IT.
GERALDO WOULD DO IT.
I WOULD DO IT.
>> YEAH, AND SEAN, EVEN WORSE,
YOU LOOK AT PETER STRZOK'S
TASKSES FROM THE DAY
LINDSEY GRAHAM ASKED ABOUT THE
UNMASKING OF FLYNN, PETER STRZOK
AND HIS TEXTS TO LISA PAGE SAYS
HEY, THIS UNMASKING THING IS THE
INCORRECT NARRATIVE.
SEAN, I ASK YOU, WHAT DO YOU
THINK HE MEANS BY THAT?
IS IT POSSIBLE THERE WAS A FISA
ON FLYNN, TOO?
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE ONE OF THE
NEXT SHE WAS TO DROP, STAY TUNED
FOR THAT ONE.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE, IT WAS
LEAKED INTELLIGENCE ON FLYNN,